[Music]
in tragic turn of events this is sad but
I can make you see about that side that
is not if we doing the Jones music yeah
it's sad submitted by Deez Nuts this guy
sees a set article that he's like oh
sorry about your grandmother's past
no smiling take this seriously
ker yeah a wife killed herself and her
kid she had after her husband faked his
death for an insurance payout oh so she
thought her husband was dead and she's
like I can't live without him so she
killed herself and her kids found out
for his insurance scam and then he's
like well god it's like I'm gonna come
back and i'ma show them how much money
we've made with the family that's
exactly what I said - yeah this happened
in China China is only identified by his
last name which is he HD his life he's
gonna containers laughs so he okay so
he's 34 years old he turned himself in
to the police after he found out about
his wife so he bought a life-insurance
policy worth about a hundred and forty
four thousand dollars without telling
his wife that's sad and he named her as
a beneficiary and then so he drove a
borrowed car into a river we borrowed it
who's the guy bought it from he's like
no god damn it
he's just like hey Susan you know where
he is one whole week I don't have my car
throw my [ __ ] where's my [ __ ] car
whoa you talking about right now who's
he he's like I'm never letting anyone
borrow anything again it's just funny or
now cuz he's Chinese I don't know 10
times more flooding wait wait see this
is why communication is important in a
relationship
exactly her reaction to see my venting
so the scam would yeah he was like my
wife is not the best act
yeah he over thought maybe he told her
before like hey we're gonna surprise our
daughter and she's like yeah she kind of
like burnt it out so he's like it has to
be authentic thinking that he was dead
his wife was 31 years old died her
name's - I what the [ __ ] we died and she
died he died as well I think these nuts
did a good job showing up yes she left a
1000 word suicide note on WeChat and
then she disappeared with their son and
daughter aged four and two [ __ ] police
were searching them and then they found
their bodies oh this day she drowned I
always do that herself and her two Oh
three weeks later actually that's like
that sources later he didn't I was
wondering
wait look he was planning on forever I
was gonna leave her I think yeah it's
really gonna leave how is he to get the
money cuz it goes to her yeah yep I
think he wanted to make sure they were
taken care of but now that's his guilt
like his guild what he said was that he
was in like $14,000 debt because their
little daughter suffered from epilepsy
and so there was like a lot of debt from
medical bills for treating her epilepsy
and also car loans and that's why he
decided to do this insurance fraud so he
was gonna disappear for three weeks just
to make it believable and then come back
well I don't know for how long she
killed herself after Derby possibly
could come back as a neighbor or uncle
yeah girl beard yeah a Gilligan hat I
don't take years girl she's Chinese to
me that I feel like he didn't think this
through really definitely didn't think
this through well he probably put a lot
of thought into it yeah a prime example
of what [ __ ] goes wrong this is like a
hilarious that's like he should have
done is like left the letter too much
evidence though yeah I don't know like a
like a [ __ ] voicemail that [ __ ]
burns after you listen to it those are
so easy to make
yeah yeah so true should have made that
I mean why couldn't he just tell her oh
I know he should have had a code that he
tells her beforehand like if I ever
leave a blue rose and the cabinet I'm
not dead but then acting I know but so
it's a place where she can't find it
immediately if she finds it after a
couple days maybe cuz he knew that she
would not let his ass go she's like that
[ __ ] is not dead tell him to
come back here right like three weeks
with two kids she's like I'll pay you
two on a grand yeah
what if yeah he's like she's not gonna
buy this [ __ ] she's not gonna be okay
with it so in her suicide note she
mentioned that he's family complained
that she spent too much cash and
suffered from mental illness only as she
was saying this is her quote I wanted to
leave by myself but thinking that my
children would suffer without both their
parents I decided to take them with me
she had also lost both of her parents
when she was so now he's gonna go to
jail for insurance fraud yep and then he
lost his whole family exactly
her dad died and later she found out the
mom had been contemplating suicide at
that time because of that and she was
like oh my god you were gonna leave me
and she's like no I would have taken you
with me oh my mom said the same thing
she was ten oh my god just ten Jesus my
mom was like yeah at one time I wanted
to go to the beach and [ __ ] drown
each other I'm like you can't swim but I
can and I'm bigger than you why do we
like 12 maybe cuz it's violent not that
silent oh that's true I can't even kill
a grasshopper
we know but she was I was gonna walk
into the ocean with you but I was like
[ __ ] we're like the same height I will
grab your ass and pick you back up and
go over like she told me like a year or
two after this is why she wanted to kill
you because you're always challenging
everything that she says what was your
mom thinking of killing herself she got
depressed after my dad left and she was
like in the room for ages and then so
yeah and then a year later she got her
energy back up and then so like we just
had a heart-to-heart she was like I was
gonna kill you and me I was like yeah
right my brother wasn't living with us
anymore yeah yeah he's he's like 12
years older than me so he was like 24
yeah but she's all dramatic about it I
don't know I just played out really
funny because she's a small woman he's
trying to make this like no but it's not
just thing because I dunno what you're
saying because your mom's very tiny yeah
she's okay hard to do damage no she was
like talking about it seriously and it
was hard for me to take it seriously
because I'm like how the [ __ ] are you
gonna even get me in that water
she had this dream like that would only
make sense if you were like four yeah I
think but you're like a 12 year old like
big yeah and I think she forgets that
the age difference she would still do
this thing where like every time she
stops she does she stops and I'm like go
put your hands on the steering wheel
that shit's more dangerous we're
stopping and she's like [ __ ] are you
and like this [ __ ] big it's not gonna
stop me that's like [ __ ] Vanessa when
she would drive me around
I shoot me she goes let me tell you
something if I'm flying out your arm
would be ripped apart tiny little bit
nummies arm is not gonna do anything arm
come on man see bonus for what what is
arm gonna do yeah I don't know what that
is so cuz I do that even if there's a
strip grocery bag there or like super
groceries cuz they roll like I don't
know it's beautiful yeah fries ik the
[ __ ] that kid right no Isaac's good he's
in a seatbelt fine he has his people
this peoples gonna protect him more than
my arm sure I can't be felt on my purse
usually that's dude we just debunked you
are you just a bunkie for a seat belt on
my plant once because I thought it was a
person because Steve's car thinks that
people are sitting there Oh cuz they
wouldn't go dude yeah it's like put a
seat belt on [ __ ] all the new cars
they're so annoying the waited yeah such
a [ __ ] when you're moving dude it's
like you're using your heart of move
[ __ ] you know like that's what I had to
do at buckled into my plant
you can buckle it behind you think about
me is I'm a dumb man so I put all the
[ __ ] in the car and there's so much [ __ ]
in the car already that I can't get the
see pot around all the [ __ ] yes the
whole time if you ever wanted to leave
me yeah all of this stuff is in his car
already you got so much [ __ ] now because
she went nuts never had that space
before and now you want to use it I'm
moving us I'm not paying any [ __ ]
movers then I'm not gonna just stand man
oh but it's such a make you but you know
she got so much pepper spice that I'm
[ __ ] getting movers longer the [ __ ]
I'm letting go
I wish we had too much stuff man all day
I'm like please I don't even want to be
in the house just move it can you just
watch so they don't steal [ __ ] we move
oh yeah I was the only thing I moved was
guns and [ __ ] money
oh now when you come over
we'll be all nice and decorative because
there's always stuff there wait so it's
gonna be even more decorated than it is
you have no idea you haven't even seen
it since we did the closet or what isn't
even that decorated you Jess yeah
remember you showed my office and it was
like it's a mess because they just moved
in then people were like that doesn't
look very inspiring in there and I was
like commented that this Joe was like oh
because we're creative artists people
that's why it's a mess in there because
our like thoughts are everywhere and
someone's like oh yeah doesn't look very
creative or it's like you should see my
[ __ ] just mowing God you should see his
room my room looks like it just never
gets cleaned immaculate you you're so
nice oh dude our place looks nuts it
looks good now B it was just they didn't
none of that stuff had anywhere to go
cuz I didn't decorate it yet anything in
there if I clean has to be one thing I
can't do something and then clean only
cooking I could do that yeah but then
you actually clean most of the time I
found out that I try to make up
psychological reasons why I can't clean
that's exactly you just did where it's
like well I come to find that if I'm if
I'm doing something creative I can't
also clean yeah it's just nothing but
excuses that aren't exactly it's
constant it's like don't you know my
process I could just [ __ ] clean a
room I can set one day to clean that's
my reset reset day what if I'm working
see ya it's a process
hey I can't like your slow-moving ball
my friend I can't do it to turn around
he needs to take my desk no I'm with you
Joe longest has been here
I know shittiest at one in one day this
will go away and it'll come right back I
guarantee I know because I clean it all
the time for you and thank you very much
it's because I get distracted if I'm
trying to do too many things and in the
day so I start cleaning and then I just
start getting distracted by work and
then an email pops up so I do have to
like set aside just cleaning what do we
do we get extra money and pay somebody
to do it
yep that's the dream
they don't tidy they just clean like
scrub
I'm down with tidying everything yeah
you scrub yeah get somebody who like
actually cleans cuz I hate the whole
thing ones like you gotta clean for your
mail but what says we just said that no
I know about how do you get that tidy
Heidi up that's what that's called
yes pick up things oh but I want to do
that I want to just pay somebody to do
the whole thing
well then get an actual maid oh yeah
live-in maid like super rich people a
lot of tiny chairs maids they have a
team I feel like there's maids that will
tidy up too yeah you just have to pay
him a little bit more or you can just do
the Marie Kondo are life-changing magic
of tidying up the [ __ ] is that get rid
of all your [ __ ] and then you buy like
one organizational thing where
everything has a home and then it's
really easy to keep it clean I don't
want to get rid of my [ __ ] I do like to
clean sometimes before I work me to me
up potato and set yeah
[Music]
you